[Musique]
[Musique] [Musique] [
Musique]
jebadiah casita privilège que nous voyons un
cancer de boxeur apparent
vous voyez une cartouche de co2 contrôlée ou
métrique allen 104 sélection en faveur du
contrôle délégué Ishida
[Musique]
Je suis constamment à la recherche de nouvelles sortes de
cultures et  idées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Jinna ne regrette rien non je veux dire non chaque
mot nous n'avions aucune interaction d'affaires
et je ressens toujours cela
[Musique]
il en faut si peu pour faire quelque chose et
les gens sont souvent très dépassés quand
ils pensent aux lieux  comme l'Afrique et
ils pensent que c'est que les problèmes sont si
graves qu'il n'y a rien que je puisse faire mais il y a
tellement de choses que nous pouvons tous faire